there was a lot that director Sophia had
to think about when casting Elvis and
Priscilla Presley before she landed on
Jacob elordi and kayy spany as for
Priscilla the years of her life that
take place in the film span from her
early teens to her 30s I really wanted
one actress to play Priscilla and she
had to play from 14 to 29 she had many
fans in the biz who recommended her to
ca has this baby face she can pass for
15 she's just so thoughtful and um a
knew that she would approach this with
sensitivity it's clear that cppo was
confident that kayy was the woman for
the job now as for Elvis the rules
requirements were a bit different the
idea of Elvis is so daunting nobody
looks like Elvis he's such a big
character and it was really important to
me to not have a character CH that still
Jacob managed to fit this very specific
bill and when I met Jacob I felt like he
has that just a Charisma and the feeling
that I could feel that he could pull
this off